tor so for example if we were in Los
Angeles and we were looking at Bloods
and Crips what we would do is we would
teach what we call knowledge of self
classes oftentimes the african-american
community and the Latino community in
the United States does not ever get to
learn its history in US schools so we
begin by teaching young people what
their history is when they begin to know
who they are they have knowledge of self
they begin to have pride in who they are
then we begin to me what Maslow talked
about the hierarchy of needs if a young
person is hungry if they're homeless if
they're struggling how do we help them
meet their material needs in a safe way
in a way that no one has to be violent
so as material needs are being met as
they're learning their history then we
begin to look at our community and say
why does our community look this way why
are there so many liquor stores and very
few community centers what can we do
then we take an activist approach of
civic engagement and begin to organize
and about six months later we bring
these two rivals together where we do
something that we've been doing since
the beginning of time which is we break
bread we eat dinner together for the
first time rivals from different gangs
if we call it homies dinner and we begin
to learn we have a lot much more in
common than we do apart and that takes
time not everybody comes some people are
really scared of that we've brokered
relationships with nonprofits like the
YMCA here in the United States to be
able to do that work and it's been
powerful to see young people begin to
transform their lives and think of
themselves as warriors for change in a
peaceful way so what motivates you to
set this up I taught history for 15
years in California and every year I
went to more funerals than I ever went
to graduations every year that broke my
heart I felt like I was going up against
the stream and I just saw that the
problems of violence there's all kinds
of violence that I began to understand
is it violent when there are no food
outlets for people is it violent when
the level of poverty is intense in a
particular late neighborhood is it
violent when a community is flooded with
guns
and drugs and living in this
neighborhood living in Compton and
living in Oakland for 23 years I
realized we have to try something
different and we've tried gang
prevention for 60 years now name a gang
prevention program that has been
completely successful that doesn't exist
so what if gangs aren't just negative
what if they're not just evil
what if something good could come out of
gangs what if young people could take
care of their neighborhoods not just in
California but in London or in places
all over the world why should we
demonize young people why don't we try
to understand why they join these places
and that motivated me to begin and
through a lot of trial and error we
landed on the idea who doesn't want to
be around a space where there's love
support camaraderie and empowerment and
that's the recipe that we've been
cooking up in homies empowerment